duras palabras en ginebra contra las
violaciones a los derechos humanos en
tigre en el consejo de la onu de
derechos humanos expresó preocupación
por los abusos cometidos por etiopía y
eritrea y pidió la retirada de las
tropas eritreas señalando las de agravar
el conflicto
la resolución propuesta por la unión
europea tuvo 20 votos a favor 14 en
contra y 13 abstenciones
la situación sobre el terreno no ha
mejorado y seguimos muy preocupados la
gente está sufriendo en tigre
intégrate eritrea en un inicio negó la
presencia de sus tropas en apoyo al
gobierno central de etiopía ahora
rechazan haber cometido abusos
la desequilibrada resolución ignora el
inicio de la crisis y traslada la culpa
a ciertos actores olvidando al principal
responsable de la cuestión
christina gdem en cal creed en depresión
la escalada internacional del conflicto
también ha desvelado aliados del
gobierno de etiopía china y venezuela
presentaron junto a eritrea más de una
docena de enmiendas
la resolución no refleja los esfuerzos
del gobierno de etiopía para mejorar la
asistencia humanitaria
aplicar a la situación del tigre los
enfrentamientos empezaron en tigre hace
8 meses entre el frente de liberación
popular de tigre gobernante en la región
y el gobierno del primer ministro y
premio nobel de la paz había metal y que
lanzó una cruenta ofensiva para sacarlo
del poder el conflicto ha dejado
centenares de fallecidos dos millones de
desplazados y 400.000 personas al borde
de la hambruna
durante meses la región estuvo cerrada a
la llegada de ayuda humanitaria que por
fin ha comenzado a fluir a través del
programa mundial de alimentos de la onu